[Música]
son las 8:30 de la noche en Bogotá quito
y Lima continuamos en directo América
edición nocturna seguimos comentándoles
los principales hechos del día Les
agradecemos su sintonía y vamos con los
titulares de esta jornada
en el último día de visita de estado a
Estados Unidos el presidente de Francia
Manuel macan continúa en la ciudad de
New Orleans antigua Colonia francesa
donde su gobierno firmó un acuerdo sobre
transición energética con el gobernador
de Luisiana para abrir oportunidades de
inversión extranjera a impulsar la meta
de cero emisiones de carbono ampliamos
con nuestra enviada especial
la Unión Europea el g7 y Australia
fijaron en 60 dólares por barril el
precio máximo para el petróleo ruso en
el caso del bloque europeo el tope no lo
afecta directamente porque a partir del
lunes aplica el embargo total al crudo
ruso se trata de la más reciente
represalia internacional por la guerra
en Ucrania tenemos análisis
Bolivia fijó la fecha del censo de
población Para marzo de 2024 el anuncio
llega tras las protestas ciudadanas en
Santa Cruz que dejaron cuatro muertos y
cientos de heridos en reclamo de un
censo para 2023 que actualice su
representación legislativa y la cantidad
de fondos estatales que recibe
[Música]
[Aplausos]
damos inicio en la ciudad estadounidense
de Nueva Orleans el presidente de
Francia Emanuel macón finaliza este
viernes su visita de estado a Estados
Unidos en el estado de Luisiana que en
el pasado perteneció a Francia y Dónde
quedan unos pequeños remanentes de
ciudadanos cuya lengua materna es el
francés justamente uno de los motivos de
su visita es reforzar y Buscar
mecanismos para garantizar la
supervivencia del idioma en esa zona
precisamente el mandatario francés habló
frente a personalidades del estado y
Defensores de la francofonía vamos a
Nueva Orleans Allí se encuentra mamen
sala con más información Amén este está
haciendo un viaje mucho más productivo
de lo que se anunció en la agenda del
presidente macron el mandatario incluso
Tuvo una reunión inesperada hoy
Sí así es después de ese discurso que
ofreció en el Museo de Arte de Nueva
Orleans como decías con personalidades
del mundo de la cultura y en defensa de
lenguaje el lenguaje y la cultura
francesa se ha sabido y además esto no
estaba en esa agenda que se compartió
con los medios de comunicación que se ha
reunido también con el nuevo presidente
de la plataforma Twitter en lo más un
hombre que ha estado en todos los
titulares en estos últimos días el mismo
presidente Emmanuel macron ha compartido
parte de esta conversación a través de
su Twitter ha dicho que en un momento en
el que Europa en el que Francia Mira
hacia la descarbonización se ha reunido
con él lo más para crear pues políticas
fabricación de vehículos eléctricos y
baterías eléctricas también se ha podido
también hemos podido saber que han
estado hablando también sobre las
políticas de control por parte de la
plataforma para que cuadren para que
comulguen un poco digamos con las leyes
de Europa por ejemplo el refuerzo de la
moderación de contenido no solo o la
protección en la libertad de expresión
Así que desde luego un viaje mucho más
productivo de lo que se esperaba Amén y
qué resta en la agenda oficial del
mandatario francés en Estados Unidos
Sí una vez que termine ese encuentro en
el Museo de Arte de New Orleans el
presidente de Francia Manuel macron se
reunirá con su esposa la primera dama
Brigitte macron irán a cenar a uno de
los restaurantes más conocidos aquí en
la ciudad de New Orleans Allí se
reunirán también con personalidades
destacadas del mundo del cine y de la
música y a continuación se espera que el
presidente pase por french Man Street
que es una de las calles más famosas de
esta ciudad donde podrá disfrutar Pues
de la atracción turística más famosa de
este lugar que es la música en directo
sobre todo del jazz y por supuesto en
medio de una gran multitud de gente aquí
es muy interesante ver como todo el
mundo está pendiente de la visita del
presidente francés porque recordemos que
no pasaba por aquí un presidente francés
desde hace casi 50 años estaba previsto
que Manuel macron viniera a celebrarlos
el 300 aniversario de la ciudad de Nueva
Jersey en el 2018 pero no fue posible
Así que era una visita desde luego muy
esperada
más o menos usted muchas gracias por
esta ampliación estamos muy pendientes
de este final de la visita del
presidente macom cambiamos de tema los
países de la Unión Europea acordaron
fijar un tope al precio del petróleo
ruso el límite quedó establecido en 60
dólares por barril y se trata de la más
reciente represalia por la guerra en
Ucrania posteriormente Las Naciones del
g7 y Australia se unieron a la medida
Moscú ya había reaccionado ante esta
posibilidad y aseguró que prohibiría la
venta de petróleo los países que
apliquen tope a los precios de la
energía para analizar esta información
conectamos con Luis Pacheco les analista
petrolero y académico no residente del
Baker institute en Rise University
bienvenido France 24 esta medida
beneficia a los mercados mundiales puede
ayudar con la estabilidad
bueno la idea principal del cap era
tratar de que el mercado no sufriera O
sea que Rusia siguiera suministrando
mientras que al mismo tiempo se trata de
limitar los ingresos que Rusia recibe de
eso
yo creo que empieza con un poco con un
pie cojo porque el precio que le están
poniendo es está por arriba de lo que
está hoy día realizando Rusia en los
mercados en los que sí vende Y todavía
tenemos que ver como reacciona Rusia
esto y cómo reacciona la reunión de el
domingo bueno sabemos que Rusia había
amenazado con prohibir la venta de
petróleo a los países que impusieran un
precio máximo a la electricidad a la
energía Rusia podría cumplir este
pronunciamiento
bueno el que el que quiera predecir lo
que puede hacer Putin tiene que tener
ser bastante humilde porque puede ser
que se equivoque Este no es fácil
decirlo o sea ese impondría un dolor
financiero importante en Rusia Pero uno
no sabe cómo puede reaccionar Putin bajo
estas circunstancias bueno Y si el
kremlin cumple esta amenaza quién se
verá más afectado Rusia o las otras
naciones
los dos este Pero va a depender también
como te dije la reacción de la OPEP si
la ope reacciona
a la salida de algunos volúmenes
importantes del mercado subiendo su
producción que luce como improbable
porque están produciendo casi todo a lo
que pueden Entonces sí tendríamos un
problema importante de precio y de
suministro en última instancia pues
señor Pacheco usted muchas gracias por
su análisis y por compartirlo con
nosotros en France 24
continuamos ahora con información de la
guerra en Ucrania porque la ciudad de
bahamut ubicada en la región del
donbadas está siendo fuertemente atacada
por el ejército ruso que busca
controlarla tras más de 10 meses de
guerra mosco intentado por todos los
medios que la ciudad caiga en sus manos
pero hasta el momento no ha tenido éxito
quién acusa al paramilitar grupo Wagner
de los ataques Andrés granadillo tiene
los detalles
bajo el asedio ruso las tropas del
kremlin quieren a toda Costa hacerse con
esta ciudad del Don vast que se
encuentra en una vía principal que
conduce a las ciudades de eslobians y
kramators según los hombres en el frente
las acciones de las tropas de Moscú
parecen desesperadas
el enemigo intensificó sus actividades
incluyendo la guerra electrónica
probablemente hay un cementerio de
drones tanto de sus drones alcanzados
por nosotros como de los nuestros
a buscar por su equipo y su aspecto sus
acciones y movimientos simplemente se
están arrastrando corriendo caminando no
tienen personal militar en ni tácticas
los paramédicos de la línea de batalla
intentan ayudar a los heridos entonces
este trabajo es diferente porque tienes
un periodo muy pequeño de bajas muy
altas y hay mucho que hacer es muy
rápido y todos los batallones tienen
bajas y tienes que tratarlas rápidamente
y dura como una semana y se acaba Así
que o ganamos o nos vemos obligados a
retirarnos muy bien
los ucranianos informaron de un intenso
bombardeo contra varias aldeas cerca de
la ciudad infligidos en gran parte Según
kiev por mercenarios del grupo Wagner un
grupo paramilitar que estaría financiado
por Moscú Wagner fue fundado en 2014
tras la anexión rusa de crimea y ha dado
apoyo a los separatistas prorusos del
Don vast también habrían participado en
la arremetida rusa en otras partes de
Ucrania según la inteligencia
y británica la Organización Mundial de
la Salud manifestó su satisfacción luego
de que las autoridades de chinas
aseguraran que comienzan a relajar sus
restricciones anticovid 19 a raíz de las
protestas en todo el país por la
respuesta pandémica de línea dura de
Beijing pero aunque la OMS resaltó la
situación en el país asiático alertó que
la relajación de las medidas en el mundo
podría llevar a la aparición de nuevas
variantes mucho más agresivas escuchamos
al director de emergencias de la
organización Michael
nos complace saber que las autoridades
chinas están Ajustando sus estrategias
actuales y realmente tratando de
calibrar ahora las medidas de control
que necesitan para este virus en sus
vidas en los medios de subsistencia y
los Derechos Humanos de las personas en
las comunidades que han como todo el
mundo sufrido
Todos hemos tenido que lidiar con
restricciones de movimiento Todos hemos
tenido que lidiar con cambios en
nuestras vidas
vamos ahora América Latina porque el
gobierno de Bolivia promulgó la ley de
censo que estipula que la medición
poblacional se realizará el 23 de marzo
de 2024 la normativa fue la más reciente
exigencia de quienes se manifestaban en
la ciudad de Santa Cruz y que en
principio pedían que ese censo se
realizara en 2023 Pues con él se
determina Cuánto dinero se le otorga a
las provincias marybaca corresponsal en
La Paz nos dio más detalles el
presidente Luis Arce ha promulgado la
polémica ley del censo aquella por la
que Santa Cruz ha realizado un paro de
36 días y que permitirá la
redistribución de recursos económicos a
las regiones con base en los datos
censales a partir de septiembre de 2024
y que además permitirá que se
redistribuyan los escaños parlamentarios
antes de las elecciones de 2025 durante
su discurso el presidente Arce ha
fustigado duramente a la oposición
cruceña ha señalado que Durante los días
de paro se han producido muertos heridos
y actos de racismo que no quedarán en la
impunidad por eso ha anunciado procesos
a nivel nacional e internacional para
asentar un precedente en contra de los
responsables de estos hechos el
gobernador de Santa Cruz Luis Fernando
Camacho ha respondido que lo que está
haciendo Luis Arce es Bajar una línea
represiva en contra de Santa Cruz y
además ha acusado a los dirigentes del
partido oficialista de ser los
responsables de la violencia ocurrida
Durante los días del paro Luis Arce
durante su discurso además se ha
referido a la profunda crisis por la que
atraviesa su partido el movimiento al
socialismo ha dicho que existe gente
dentro de sus filas que busca acortar su
mandato y que quiere verlo fracasar de
hecho antes de que Arce promulgara el la
ley del censo el expresidente Evo
Morales ha señalado que el presidente
está a punto de cometer un error
histórico de hecho y sus seguidores
acusan al gobierno de Arce de haber
traicionado al movimiento al socialismo
Al haber aprobado esta ley porque
consideran que es una concesión a la
derecha de Santa Cruz en otras noticias
el presidente electo de Brasil Luis
Ignacio Lula da Silva aseguró que antes
de asumir el cargo se reunirá con Joe
biden según el próximo jefe de estado de
Brasil hay muchos temas en la agenda
incluso lo que llamó estragos causados
en la democracia de ambos países por
Donald Trump y Yair bolsonaro Lula dijo
que definir a la fecha de su visita tras
la reunión que sostendrá el próximo
lunes con el asesor de seguridad
Nacional de la casa blanca y aclaró que
el viaje se realizará luego de que las
autoridades electorales le entreguen su
diploma de mandatario electo
y avanza la edición número 36 de la
Feria Internacional del Libro de
Guadalajara en México y France 24 está
presente el emirato de sharja el tercero
más grande de emiratos árabes Unidos es
el invitado en este 2022 nuestra enviado
especial de Israel habló con el poeta
adonis una de las voces más importantes
de la literatura árabe en la actualidad
la Feria Internacional del Libro de
Guadalajara están viendo sus últimos
días aquí en México una edición número
36 marcada por la participación de más
de 600 escritores de 45 países distintos
y 18 idiomas diferentes y se nota que
este año la feria está mirando hacia el
mundo árabe por primera vez el tercero
más grande de los siete y emiratos que
conforman los emiratos árabes Unidos es
el invitado de honor de la feria y del
lado de los artistas algunas voces
importantes de la literatura en árabe
estándar presentes como el palestino
de la poesía moderna árabe y es su
primera vez en la feria del libro de
Guadalajara nos compartió su alegría de
estar acá
es muy importante tener ferias como esta
porque es realmente un punto de
encuentro extraordinario y casi único la
One
ahí estamos todos de todas las lenguas y
nacionalidades o civilizaciones todos en
la misma casa y eso demuestra que el
hombre puede crear un mundo de paz y
amistad dejemos Las Guerras el
capitalismo y todo eso
le sontón
después de nueve días de conferencias
entre Editores autores y lectores la
Feria Internacional del Libro de
Guadalajara serárá sus puertas este
domingo Así llegamos al final de esta
misión de directo América que en France
24 ustedes Les agradecemos su sintonía y
los invitamos a que continúen con
nosotros que ya llega a Raúl blanco con
toda la información del continente
americano enamérica feliz noche para
todos
[Música]